Trascrizione: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Revisore: Andrea Busetto
(Musica)
(Applausi)
Salve.
Io mi chiamo Fausto D'Elia
e rappresento il team XCUBE 3D.
Ma cos'è XCUBE 3D?
Potremmo definirla
una nuova espressione artistica
che si pone l'obiettivo
di colpire positivamente,
affascinare, stupire.
È grazie a questa interazione
che abbiamo cercato di creare,
l'abbiamo ideata,
progettata, lavorata.
Questa interazione fra la realtà virtuale
della videoproiezione tridimensionale
e quella tangibile
dei performer in scena.
Perché comunque noi cerchiamo,
attraverso questo,
di accompagnarvi, di coinvolgervi
in questo gioco di illusionismo virtuale.
Ovvio che dietro a tutto questo c'è
un grande lavoro, una grande sinergia
tra i performer, lo staff tecnico,
lunghe prove estenuanti.
Ovviamente bisogna calcolare il tutto
con precisione millimetrica,
valutare le prove
al millesimo di secondo,
per potervi proiettare
in questa quarta dimensione.
Ed è grazie a loro,
ai ragazzi,
che noi possiamo regalarvi
questa emozione.
Ci auguriamo
di avervi regalato delle sensazioni
dal forte impatto emotivo
perché è questo
il nostro obiettivo:
viverlo insieme a voi,
momento per momento,
pochi minuti, pochi istanti,
che richiedono un grande lavoro.
E, per completare il tutto,
abbiamo cercato di inserire
più espressioni artistiche o sportive.
Oggi, in questa breve presentazione
che abbiamo portato qui al TEDx,
c'è solo una parte dello staff
con alcune espressioni fuse tra di loro.
Abbiamo, per la ginnastica ritmica:
Giorgia Marra.
(Applausi)
Magia e illusionismo:
il nostro mago Rudy
(Applausi)
Splendido ballerino di hip-hop
ma anche coreografo,
coprogettista di ciò che è XCUBE 3D,
Alessio Perrone.
(Applausi)
In regia video, tecnico, grafico 3D
nonché coideatore di XCUBE 3D
Fabio Cascione
(Applausi)
Credetemi, per noi è
veramente un piacere e un onore
essere qui ad aprire
questo splendido appuntamento.
E vogliamo ringraziare
Andrea Pauri.
Vogliamo ringraziare
tutto il pubblico presente,
tutte le persone
che hanno contribuito
per realizzare
questo splendido appuntamento.
Grazie ancora a tutti quanti
da parte nostra.
(Applausi)